so the 149 you know passengers on board  ET 302 we can now confirm that the way  at least 35 at least 35 nationalities  and I'm saying at least because as of  now to unknown so among the most  affected as you may expect is Kenya  which heard about that two passengers on  board out of the 149 passengers other  nationalities involved with the number  of passages in the flight were Canada  with 18 Canada with 18 China with five  sorry China with eight never odds with  five Egypt with six Ethiopia  with nine France UK seven each India  before Italy with eight and then we have  silver Kia with four in the USA with  eight the other nationalities who have  like one or two fighters on board as I  said this information has to come from  sauce  European airlines and with me as manager  the line to the press conference there  in Nairobi but the headline coming out  of that press conference was that there  were seven UK nationals on board that  flight which tragically crashed this  morning